hello everyone and thank you for joining
today's session where we'll be covering
new use cases in cloud data threat data
pipeline and new connectors we're super
excited to share what's new for cloud
data prep and in particular two new
additions turn out for thousands of
hours of hard work and of Engineering
has been dedicated to release what we
think is the ultimate and most advanced
data preparation solution ever designed
for the town I am Bertram car.you
product marketing manager for cloud data
prep I have been with trifecta for the
last five years I had a long background
working in the data and analytics face
as a practitioner and with software
vendors I am delighted to host this
webinar which an MA product manager
responsible for cloud the different
shanlee want to quickly introduce
yourself sure
thanks for Trond hi my name is Sean MA
I've been which I factor for the last
six years as Bertrand just said I'm the
product manager for cloud dinner prep
I've been working with Google cloud on
this joint product for many years since
the very beginning over the last four
years it's been our privilege to watch
how the inter prep has grown and help
solve data challenges for many types of
users whether they be data analysts
engineers or scientists
thanks to tons of feedback from the
users we really hope that we've been
able to listen and channel that feedback
into some of the new capabilities that
you're going to see today
with that let's get started thank you so
here is the agenda for the next 25
minutes will be first covering cloud
data fetch RNA which started four years
ago as intersection and we have achieved
a lot through that journey especially we
learn new use cases such as cloud
analytics modernization marketing
analytics pricing optimization retails
an empty forever even manufacturing
analytics we have released two new
additions to support all these new use
case and shin malphur than wind in the
details
Chen will then go over demo so you can
see when the new additions with
look like after a quick recap decision
will be open for question that you can
submit through the chat or also you can
request one ones meeting session with
our experts in the next couple weeks
that further the decision you watch the
session so let's get started so before
we deep dive in the new capabilities a
new product I wanted to to review in
couple of minutes an overview that will
be for most of you maybe a refresh but I
want you to go back to the background of
cloud data thread so dear friend is
developed by trifecta in partnership
with Google child trifecta as a
companion as a product is the recognized
leader in data preparation trifecta also
first solution that ran on over cloud
platforms it runs also on on its own
trifecta SAS or on-premise so you can
really select the version of the product
that fits your needs cloud data prep on
the Google cloud is the service and only
native to the Google Cloud Data
Corporation solution as part of the
rotor Google cloud smart analytics
wheels cloud their prep allows data
analyst is nestled on instead engineers
and data scientists to explore team and
preferred Big Data visual as you can see
on the left of the string cloud that
connects to the query Cloud Storage
Google sheets as well as traditional
databases and cloud apps at the center
you can see that cloud better practice
is built on top of dataflow what it
means is that any data transformation
and cleaning rules that design in cloud
that upfront is push down to data flow
and can easily scale to transform any
data
big or small now focusing on the right
part of the diagram once your data is
ready in the query or cloud storage you
can analyze it will cloud data studio or
lucre you can train machine learning
models with Google Cloud
services or you can even get inside from
over partner BI solutions such as sleep
or tablet now if we just focus on the
bottom of the screen Trombetta friend is
a native services to google cloud
it delivers with provides api is that we
can leverage with over technology of
Google technologies such as cloud
composer who IP is to schedule and to
orchestrate cloud better fret or
leverage cloud functions for example
when a file arrives in Google Cloud
Storage you can trigger a cloud dataflow
so this is a summary of an overview of
cloud data threat and where it fits in
in the Google cloud so now let's get to
the core of this presentation
thanks to tremendous adaption since 2000
c17 by over hundred of thousand of user
were able to capture requirements for
new and advanced espaces
these results in the launch of two new
cloud there prepositions the store
definition and the premium edition that
support new use case more flexibility
also in pricing that we can offer so
plunderer pred is now based on a six
project basis pricing which you can try
for free so you can really start free
with cloud data prep to try all these
new features you can also get now direct
access to trifecta support trainings and
professional services with cloud data
prep premium you
you now have advanced connectivity with
Google sheets data bases and
clarifications and we'll cover in the
details and demo it there there there is
also new they have pipeline capabilities
with a brand new job orchestration
workspace with tasks sequencing others
when hoops advance at API to integrate
child effort with broader
our analytic applications and you've got
also data processing optimization and
data flow for even faster performances
Katdare prep also get some options for
fine-grained permissions and management
for end-users Chan will deep dive in if
you said you know all these capabilities
so content prep Stoner and premium are
available now you can see at the bottom
of the screen the link you should be
marked is just go to the marketplace the
google cloud marketplace we search for
trifecta you'll find it however cloud
data prep is also still part of the
world cloud console that we know best so
you can sign up on the marketplace or on
the Google Cloud console so now I'll end
it over to share to go over the details
of their prep and summer and premium
trial it's all yours
sure thanks so I'm gonna cover four
categories where cloud dinner prep is
either new or significantly improved in
both the existing product as well as the
new standard and premium editions so the
first area we're going to cover is our
new self-service connectors which allow
us to easily access all your data from
within data prep itself while native GCP
connectivity to various sources and
targets has always been there you don't
always have your initial starting point
of data in cloud storage or bigquery
a common point example of this is Google
sheets which businesses use as a primary
method for collecting and sharing data
typically they want to combine this data
with tables and bigquery or standardize
it against files in cloud storage in
this case cloud data preps goal is to
provide the same familiar search
experience that Google Drive has to
these same users so they can easily find
and import that data set directly into
data prep without any additional
configuration as a bonus there is no
limit to the size of data or the number
of sheets that you can import for
example in cases where there are new
sheets being added to a single G Street
document every day you can configure
cloud data prep to automatically pick up
all these new sheet
and add them to the existing data source
without having to make any changes to
your recipe
in other cases users need quick access
to a handful of sources typically found
in traditional databases so I had to do
a lookup or maybe fetch the latest delta
of data that's available in the database
itself this is where the new relational
connectors such as Oracle's sequel
server Postgres just to name a few come
in handy as well as application
connectors to Salesforce make it easy
for you to grab all the necessary data
from a single interface by just simply
selecting from one of the existing
connections last but not least bigquery
continues to be the primary source and
target for majority of the data prep
users and we continue to make key
improvements in this area such as
automatic column filtering which is a
huge performance gain because what it
does is automatically prune some of the
columns that you aren't using so you
process less data and the whole result
comes back faster on the flexibility
side we now allow custom sequel data
sets which means users can create their
own standard sequel statement and
actually import that and use that as a
data source itself ok let's move on to
the next slide as usual to build longer
recipes and continue to combine more
data sources we've seen the size and
complexity of their data prep flows
increased dramatically thanks to vocal
feedback from our community we've
revamped the flow UI for improved
productivity now you can drag and drop
your recipes your sources and even your
outputs you do customized layouts and
you have easy access to common
transformations like Union or join
directly from the flow the addition of
email notifications and web hook tasks
allow you to configure who and how you
want other users or services to be
alerted when data prep jobs are
completed this can be configured to
start immediately after a job has been
completed successfully or you can send
an email or in the case of failure maybe
you need to notify a down train system
whatever use case best fits your needs
we should be able to support that a big
development is the addition of recipe
parameters which allow you to make a
recipe behave dynamically based on
inputs that are inserted at job
execution time this is critical for
share
reusability where one user creates a
common piece of logic that can be used
by many others users can achieve this by
defining recipe steps with parameters
that change the logic based on the input
a common example is financial
calculations which often need the latest
currency conversion rates to be passed
in at the time of run and so now you can
do that without having to modify the
recipe at all and last thing to note in
order to round out reasonability we've
made it much easier to import expert
flows across projects this makes it much
easier to jumpstart a new initiative by
simply migrating a copy of your flows
and recipes to another user so they can
start getting started with data prep
from there
floo by itself is not always enough
sometimes you might need to chain
together multiple flows or need to
combine them with external services so
you can achieve your end end use case
that's why we're introducing a brand new
visual interface cloud data prep plans
that orchestrate multiple tasks within
the enterprise not only can you visually
design the sequence of tasks but you can
actually monitor and their execution
status and their outputs this comes in
handy whenever one flow depends on a
earlier flow to have run completed or
you need to run a command statement or a
sequel statement before running another
flow coming soon
you'll be able to trigger these plans
based on various external events like
the arrival of a new file or an external
API call then you can build conditional
logic to decide which set of tasks you
want to execute next we also know that
many users already have existing data
pipelining tools that are used in
production today so we wanted to provide
flexibility with cloud data prep to
integrate into those existing workflows
this is why we've extended the work we
introduced last year with cloud composer
and data preps job execution api's by
adding brand-new api's to fetch
profiling and recipe metadata directly
from dinner prep these api's were
designed so that you can leverage key
metrics generated from the data prep
jobs such as data quality results
directly into your external tool through
the same workflow 12 choice ok I got one
last category but maybe it's the most
important one security and governance
we've seen the adoption data prep grows
significantly across multiple teams and
departments as a result these teams have
higher demands in terms of their
security and governance requirements to
meet this broader environment need
security has always been top of mind
with data prep which is why we've
extended our native integration with
Google iam to now add fine-grained data
access permissions within the data prep
project security has always been top of
mind with data prep so building on our
native integration of Google I am we've
added fine
access within each data prep project now
teams can control individual data set
access through a combination of google
IM rolls as well as bigquery and cloud
storage access rights there's also a
plasticy suite where you can apply
import sources like Google sheets now
when a shared Google sheet is imported
into data prep the same access rights
that were granted in G Drive are now
applied within data prep which means
only users who are authorized to see and
prepara prepare that data are the ones
who are going to access it
lastly networking has been the other
major part that we've been improving in
terms of security and the goal is to
support a much wider range of
configurations that you've set up within
your IT environment this includes custom
networks private IPS share V pcs so in
the latest edition you'll see many new
options that are available when you run
a cloud data prep job in data flow
you've always been able to run a job in
different regions from different data
centers around the world but in addition
to that now you can specify things like
a custom V PC network name sub Network
custom service names labels and you can
even fine-tune some of the execution
parameters for the data flow job itself
such as workers ok and with that let's
get into a brief demo for a few of these
key capabilities that I just covered
start with the new cloud data prep by
try factor listing that's now available
on the GCP marketplace as you can see
here it's got lots of information about
the two new additions that are available
so you can go ahead and purchase new
projects for a standard of premium or
you can upgrade an existing project once
it's purchased you can then launch the
product from the left-hand nav by
scrolling down to the Big Data section
and selecting data prep
from there it'll launch you directly
into the product and you can see which
Edition you have based on the logo up
above in this case it's premium now what
I'd like to do is actually take an
existing flow and augment it with some
of the new capabilities we just talked
about in the presentation today so with
that I'm going to click on this
particular flow customer activity and
retention and open it
inside you'll see this flow here which
is got existing recipe and output in
this case it's got an Oracle source
which is taking accounts activity data
and then it's running a recipe that
cleanses the activity data and
outputting it out to bigquery what I
want to do is augment this recipe with
data from Google sheets in this case
I've got account contact information in
Google sheets here you've got various
columns information inside of that what
I like to do as a part of this is make
sure that the data is cleansed and I can
capture all the data inside you'll see
here that I've got multiple sheets of
data with one fall by week two
so that's why I want to pull in and just
to make sure that everything is
up-to-date
I'm gonna ahead and just make a quick
modification here make that change so I
now know this is the latest one it's
been saved to my dry ok let's go back to
cloud data prep
now I add this to my flow I'll click on
add you can see here all the various
data sources that are supported GCSE
Google sheets bigquery and several
relational systems that are now
available click on Google sheets I typed
in part of the name inside there July
2020 whom the account - contact info the
one I just modified just now is
available so I can go ahead and import
that I'll just click there it's
importing into this so it's doing two
things one is checking to make sure I
have the right permissions and right
access for this in this case it's mine
so that should be easy and it's also
making sure that it captures both sheets
in this case the two sheets there as in
this case two separate data sets
during data set creation i chose instead
of making them two separate data sets i
want to combine them into one data set
this is handy if you have more sheets
coming in in the future so now it's
acting as one data set I'm going to hit
save and now I'm going to import that
into my flow
okay now we've got that data side
importer in my flow you can see the
details inside of this I want to combine
it I can do that easily but I just click
the append to this particular recipe now
what I'm gonna do is I'm going to make
sure that I'm selecting the correct data
set to join in this case account contact
info I'm gonna hit accept and it's gonna
go ahead and join through this I'm going
to skip through a couple steps just to
make this demo go a little faster but
now that it's successfully joined I can
see it there just for ease of
understanding I'm going to reposition
this so it lines up with my other
sources all right
so now for the most part I've got most
of data that I want inside this let me
go check my output yeah I've got
destination that correctly said in this
case the big query and I want to add an
action after this particular job is
completed running in this case I am
interested in kicking off a cloud
function that will analyze the output
from a successful job run to do this I
will go ahead and add a new webhook task
that executes after the job is complete
let's take a quick look at the cloud
function by pulling it up it's a simple
function that calls a scoring model
against account data I'll quickly grab
the trigger for that particular account
scoring model take that and I'll go back
to the data prep
so now when it create a web of tasks I
can give it a quick name count scoring
and I'll I will just paste the exact
same URL that I got from the trigger
I'll choose that I want this to be
happen on judge success on any
particular output and finally I'll pass
in the headers
let's go ahead and test that first just
make sure it's working okay good I
triggered it I gets called functions
I'll hit create now I have my level test
there let's finish this off by actually
running their job
you can see here in the run job view you
can choose to profile your results again
checking that out putting to the right
location then I'll set the correct
region that I'm running from this case
I'm saying I'm gonna run from Europe so
I'm sorry my data centers and which
machines I'm interested in
now we're showing you the new
capabilities that we added like
customizing your VDC network mode if you
want to choose private IP addresses and
if you want to go further and set your
auto scaling algorithms you can inside
here as well
that all looks good let me click run job
with that the job should be kicking off
as a recap of this scenario this job
will read data from Oracle and Google
sheets join them in a single recipe and
cleanse the data the Alpha will be sent
to bigquery and a cloud function will be
triggered to run a scoring algorithm on
that data once a job has completed
successfully
thanks Shannon for working as food a
demo that was a pretty comprehensive
demo and it give us a pretty good idea
of what Pat did but premium can offer to
summarize and before we wrap up there is
what what is new with cloud benefit
first
cloud era prep now comes in two editions
you get this toner edition the premium
edition and on the right can see all
these capabilities from high-level
perspective and in each elite the ones
from tamiya so don't leave without their
pet name up now offers six project based
pricing okay so you define the number of
projects you want and you get it pricing
for project however it can still start
free job data but in addition to the
Google Cloud console where you are used
to start and sign up for cloud data prep
we now have an option to start to sign
up for cloud effect from the google town
market place and it offers more
flexibility to customize the pricing
based on your usage so it's such as the
number of projects or if you want annual
or not here up from subscriptions you
get also additional direct access to the
traffic data for direct connection with
experts in cloud data plan last but not
least you can get specialized training
and services packages to get your data
preparation teams and project on track
for fast and successful delivery well
all these emissions cloud data prep is
getting to really new the level of
excellence to make sure you can cover
all your data preparation initiatives
who'da flexibility so before we close up
I wanted to get like a few links that
you should try and in fact in particular
we go
good white paper about five lessons we
learn to Arab self-service analytics in
the cloud so you'll get to understand m2
and Google Cloud smart analytics
platform and outer to make that arouse
big data initiative or data light and
where their effort plays a role and how
you need to follow through tips to
really be successful
chan I wanted to thank you for
presenting with me today yeah Thank You
Bertrand okay and thank you everyone for
attending stay safe everyone thank you
and goodbye
bye everyone